are you ready for our real fights today
Jade nostalgia critic what are we gonna
do tonight this one will probably nobody
will care about you much but they're
gonna really hate me for it uh even
though I know you don't like this movie
let's talk about the Flinstones movie
yeah yeah but Devon don't I should've
looked up who directed this cuz it's one
of those doofuses they either does like
Smurfs or like Alan and the Chipmunks or
Beverly Hills - wow that's like one of
those Jokers uh that did this movie and
um I love how you know we're always so
mean but at the same time we make crap -
at the same time I get the impression
that some of these guys that end up in
those type of movies are literally just
doing it for a paycheck
it's like b-movie directors is just like
they wrote me a check
I direct their I don't care well shit II
the script is cuz let's be honest it's
not like one of the problems with the
Flinstones is not even a good script to
begin with no not really I'm not only
like 30 Reich and Stanley Kubrick's I'm
gonna be able to fucking save the
Flintstones like yeah so well and I
think what's gonna get people really
raking on me because when I did the
review of it I said I didn't like the
Flintstones cartoon you know it oh oh
just let it they just wanted say like
how dare you sir and it's like I don't
despise it it's just nothing to me
uh we were Jetsons fan I do like the
Jetsons better
Jetsons better - but I guess a that's a
good cartoon either it's just like you
know and I guess pick your really
non-effective poison it's just kind of
bland ah but like appreciate know by
appreciate what it did we all Frisian we
got animation in primetime in sitcoms a
you know every week and that's amazing
and that's is there's a lot and can we
all agree that Gazoo was the highlight
of the series that's right dum-dums
played by the infamous Alan Cumming in
Viva rock Vegas I still haven't seen
that one yet by the way that's probably
well we might have to do down the line
cuz I hear it's very bad
um but yeah so you have here's the thing
about this Flintstones movie cuz even as
a kid I just didn't really care that
much about the Flintstone I don't hate
it I just didn't get into it I way okay
you know what I watched The Flintstones
for the animals the weird inventions yes
that no it's cool
I always loved that the wanted animal
cruelty on that show it's like we're
gonna make a Pelican a garbage disposal
like you're a dinosaur do this I'm just
like wow what an awful it's like that
Rick and Morty bit where it's just like
he creates that little robot it's it's
like what is my mission in life to pass
butter and then later as what is my
mission I told you to pass butter and he
looks down at this edge like oh my god
welcome to the clubhouse like that's
what it's got to be with these poor
animals like this is literally my lot in
life
to sit under the sink and eat garbage to
wash people's dishes to it it's when you
think about it like rationally is one of
the darkest most horrific things ever
put on fucking television but the
Simpsons did best but that's where the
Pelican Gabri I was using the Pelican as
a cement mix it's like Marge barrier if
there's anything that the Flintstones is
darkness is that animals can be used in
hilarious ways to you know do remedial
tasks like he's got like cement in this
pelicans poor mouth that it's sitting
there like ah is it gonna say something
like it's a live hand it just follows
our Jimmy stops up the Flintstones just
like when you look at it that way the
show's fucking hilarious I will say this
as a kid I honestly like Gazoo because I
was a child like you could say I like
the a leader you but I'm like like
fucking fine like when what
five-year-old wooden but it I think but
I think I was in it just for Barney
Rubble like Barney was my favorite
character
I found him amusing but wasn't in it for
pebbles or bamm-bamm or the eventual
pebbles bamm-bamm wedding which ran in
primetime they marry each other what do
you remember them well I was okay at
once I said first I gotta thought
they're brother and sister but you're
right there no neighbors okay
no I said Star Wars incest no like no
cuz that's right 1990 I want to say was
that teen night I want to say was like
1994 talked about the 70s like Awful's
advantage I mean like teenagers or
college students or something you
remember that and they have the
seventies jam god oh my god this is just
my baby all this good stuff yeah so see
what maybe maybe was a rerun but no I
remember it was like remembers like 99
years of what kazoo the barest
yes that would have been honest I was
yes you dum-dum anyway I was pissed
because I never liked pebbles and
bamm-bamm to begin with and I was a huge
fan at the time because I was fucking 10
years old of America's Funniest Home
Videos they're like we're sorry
America's Funniest Home Videos will be
interrupted tonight so we could give you
the pickles the Royal Wedding of the
year I'm serious
this is Hallie fucking announced it I'm
not making this up this happened you can
maybe find a promo for it somewhere do
you do it's like America's funny some
videos will be interrupted today because
we need to bring you the pebbles and
bamm-bamm wedding and now let us dream
the ceremony yeah it was exactly was
like princess die getting fucking
married and so I still remember to this
day cuz I was a kid that was so pissed
off and I was just like why would they
do this and I just remember our dad
being like well apparently enough people
really want to see family as only our
dad could say what is dry sense of humor
so I remember that that's a stupid shit
the Flintstones bottom why all of this
is still more interesting than
Flintstones the movie
oh so Gazoo Barney and wanted animal
cruelty is what I was into the show
actually like was it ordered though the
order of the water buffalo or the what I
don't know I actually like that group of
as well I actually have to be remind of
them the movie cuz I was like before
these guys this Allegan remember hey I
actually like the show more than I
remember I also remember the show to
watch it again well as a kid I remember
the show being just kind of boring to me
because it's just dull just like for a
kid
it's just kind of like an older sitcom
but I get it I get the time period I get
that it's harmless its innocent and it
really changed a lot in time TV
animation I'm just amazed very clever
that they were animating it before a
live studio audience that laugh track
you know I'm yeah 30 40 years before
Simpsons you know just did it a week ago
or whatever they got rid of the audience
then because you know it's like we're
all moving they want past the sitcom but
you know they have a traditional router
so the ability to do that Scooby this
strain on the animator spritz the
Simpsons would say the that kill me the
most I know we should talk about the
movie but with the laugh track even when
I was gone when I was a kid and he just
say like yeah I've heard a murder when
the audience would laugh he was a kid of
like how can it make a whole audience
laughs he just said the thing you know
he says it's not even in reference to
anything communic there was nothing
funny about this and like ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha ha ha why is that funny
even the jokes that aren't funny I get
why there's an audience laughs but why
is that funny and always show me nuts
cuz it's like it's like the trying to
really maintain the illusion that a
studio audience is watching this and
laughing it out like I just can't I
can't blend stealth I can't scooby-doo
that's why I like the Jetsons they never
did that
dee dee dee Jessica in the futures that
audience hasn't been born you're gonna
hit China soon pal uh all right but
let's talk about they love Flintstones
in China let's finally talk about this
movie this movie was hyped as hell when
it came out it was it I remember before
um Jurassic Park I mare was a a very
clever trailer cuz oh yeah you don't
want a trailer before any movie in the
early 90s I can't really that was it
like giraffes were it was like the
biggest fucking movie of the first part
of that decade and it says you know your
favorite family's coming to big-screen
they just see this little pebble going
across the layer the Flintstones meet
the flimsy and they just do the whole
song and that's
but then at the very end cuz we're all
thing is gonna be a cartoon because
that's what they still bit did back then
they had a Jetsons movie and such and
suddenly this realistic hand catches it
and you see John Goodman go
yabba-dabba-doo the audience howls I
mean they're like that's really like
we're friggin doing this play into kind
of a fun good way like this could
actually be really funny it was like
that scene in 2000 when the monkeys I
mean just like everyone just went nuts
and I even I was laughing I'm like and I
didn't care for Flintstones felt like
you were also like 11 at all so I got a
sense of humor was not edit so and then
the other trailers were coming out and
it looked okay I mean it looked like
imaginative indicia this is when CG was
really catching on and you know we just
saw the dinosaurs from Jurassic Park and
I see Dino running around and if I was
still mixing it to it's like okay this
this could be kind of fun uh and then
what do you manage to do that it's a
cartoon it is still kind of a cartoon
world so you don't have to make Dino
look really realistic huh it can be
cartoon so this movie comes out and I
just like I think the only other movie
at the time I got slammed as hard was
like Coneheads which was a little part
of their the better Daffy a little
unfairly slammed in my opinion by my
cats like it's good and just desserts a
one joke movie but at least it was a
joke
yeah and Flintstones was just getting
like destroyed by every critic and the
big thing that they were saying is that
this movie apparently had 30 writers
which nowadays is like every film
they're just not credited I mean you're
handsome too high criteria here right
this line any of funny right line here
here but I mean we talked to writers
before and they'll just do that and they
don't really get the main writing credit
like maybe somewhere that million other
credits they'll get like story editor
side note whatever one really that's
grabbing spoon a year to have earlier
get better reviews so it's obvious that
the credits were being paid off by Chuck
Jones's conditions yeah but yeah that's
what we saw except it's not very good
you know conspiracy the crooks weren't
paid a lot well any like believe
nowadays i I want get European cuz this
is something like when we're watching it
the production design
we couldn't figure out if it was
brilliant or awful because it looked
like a place of Universal Studios like a
theme park but it also kind of looks
like the cartoon to like now if it
looked that much like Rocky Kalin plasma
bright and colorful but it was also kind
of dirty and dusty and we couldn't get a
grasp on does this really work or is
this just the exact opposite handling it
had the same problem Hooke had but hook
in my opinion actually pulled it off
which is if you watch hook it's
painfully obvious it's a set like I I
mean it in a certain way it's like it's
not a Fantasyland you're on a movie set
it's really obvious it's a movie set but
that's that's amazing
but a the sets amazing and B there was
something about the way they did it that
it kind of worked it was its own thing
in the Flintstones it was the same idea
it's like this is obvious this is a
movie set but I could never suspend my
disbelief that extra step necessary like
it just I think you put it best it
looked like a theme park attraction like
you could see the robots and the
animatronics and the I felt like I was
waiting in line for you know the
Flintstones ride at Universal Studio you
know what I helped it the more I think
about it uh because when I think of that
movie I think of like a lot of brown and
yellow and even like the purples and
blues of the rocks and some are sort of
shrouded by that brown and yellow and I
know the show kind of was too but what
if they had like a like you have the
brown you have the yellow be actually
really blue sky against it well or
contrast Ithaca they seems like there's
no contrast in the color colors didn't
from what I remember of the show was
these bright characters in the
foreground you've got a man beating
orange about and then it wasn't brown it
was white
it was like stone gray white and they're
like all the houses that I remember
somebody I always remember like the
stone gray of the houses and that I I
don't know that the guy remember a lot
of hot white and I mean we kind of
bought in it um but that is but but
here's the thing we're talking about a
show that was made on the cheap I mean
when you can do anything you want now
because you've got the budget and I mean
clearly this movie had the budget it
looks like an expensive movie
um so much so that I think they only
made this equals just to get their
money's worth out well we already have
this shit lying around huh
I don't know I just feel like it could
have been more colorful I felt like the
movie was strangely monochromatic which
is weird for something based on a
cartoon show yeah uh but but but with
you know this whole thing like I don't
know I feel like there's a right way and
a wrong way to do nostalgia like the
right way is kind of like referencing
hey you remember this but we're gonna
sort of take it to like the next level
to or we're gonna kind of make fun it or
we're gonna bring something out of that
nostalgia that is either new and you
love or something that was like this is
the best part of the nostalgia well the
day we're gonna really focus on that the
Brady Bunch movie did that yeah I
thought it was more successful and being
like okay well we're going to be
respectful to a certain degree but we're
also gonna poke fun it doesn't be like
that's pretty or another example and we
references a lot the lego movie I mean
what lego movie well rights that should
be the gold standard most the focus of
that era yeah it's Legos it's nostalgia
we get it but they focused on the
creativity and imagination that
everybody has with Legos and the the
heart and you know that you want to play
with these and childhood you know
obviously with the ending and the
connection that they have they're like
that's the stuff you want to think of
okay what do you think of like I was in
vest there's my problem though and now
they can all thump on me oh oh I'll play
shield here for you for a second what
was the heart of like stones it's like
we're talking about like all the things
I make like is so great what to be
Honeymooners with caveman yeah audience
what was what was the heart and soul of
The Flintstones what did the movie miss
what legacy that's a problem like what I
I'm significant kind of it's like well
far we're gonna do affluence movie that
capture the essence of the Flintstones
what would I do it up like I can't think
of anything no I remember one joke you
can but it would be very difficult I
think the focus I guess he loved his
wife
ya know honestly that would be the honey
I guess we know what it is the honeymoon
what made the honeymooners work that's
what we need to go yeah what made the
honeymooners work and I wrote a chance
they had crazy neighbors but you know
what he really loved is
okay so we'll go with that instead Fred
gets a bunch of people fired hey it's
more about Fred and Barney's connection
in there moving even that's not what
every good I mean but that should be 50%
of it not a hundred percent and even
then it's like their friendship breaks
up in the hole I get the whole plot with
him I don't want to see Fred to become
some like vice president don't turn me
watcher can he solve it watch the
cartoon show for that um Wow maybe we
are finding the heart and soul if you
will maybe this show was deeper than we
thought
admit it and this is that time too when
all the movies like all the comedies are
kind of family-friendly we're like son I
even then just all comedies some asshole
in a suit has some sort of plan that
either involves getting everybody fired
or a microchip and in this case it's the
cuisine header
yes the doom guy poor treaties and you
know they used the main character as
some sort of sucker to bring in so he
can be silly but he has a heart of gold
so he's the hero and you root for him
the other guys clearly smarter but he
doesn't have a heart so you don't like
him and they just use that over and over
and over and over and yeah I think it
took away from what little you could do
with this or a setup but you could still
potentially which is focus on you know
the family the husband and wife kind of
goofy neighbors and just can have fun
with that but instead it's like hey
remember this scene where they went
bowling and he's on his tippy-toes we
did that yeah and what else it's like
nope that's the joke like that you know
what air punch what works in a cartoon
like that scene just was painful to me
because I'm like this this isn't funny
when you see John Goodman and some
special effects but it just it works on
the cartoon because that's what cartoons
do they exaggerate things it's like here
it's just creepy and awkward well I
don't know what what you saw with the
Brady Bunch movie that works because
they're satirizing and because they was
so removed from reality that they put it
in reality that's why that work they put
it in reality this one is in there
strange reality but they don't push it
that next step they just do what the
cartoon did and stop you know we can
watch the car to it oh we won't watch
the cartoon
watch The Honeymooners but we've got
Elizabeth Taylor yes II seriously I want
to know what the IRS had like I want
that blackmail file she was doing much
at the time anyway but it's like yeah I
like thanks for her to do the like we're
good flips we're gonna throw you in the
flintstones movie what did they have
probably though maybe surely was Wilma's
mother in the cartoon show cuz she was
around but she could've been that sounds
very very strange yeah and that even
some of the choices like you know uh you
know Goodman you know that's a fine of
Fred Goodman Goodman was actually
perfect yeah I am no Oh Rick Moranis a
surprisingly good Barney yeah would not
have been my first choice but it works
definitely not appearance wise I was not
as anti Rosie O'Donnell as Betty even
though it's like yet that looks nothing
like Betty at all but it's like she had
the lab she had it is a little
exaggerated but it's fine
I worked yeah the woman in play will
know where that is
uh um you know she was like all the act
or they traded her up with uh
what's-her-face from third son yeah yeah
they switched it out I'm gay or a name
but yeah friend Sally from 30 rock
yeah they switch them all out for that
uh but yeah it's something where it's
like the actors couldn't bring something
to this that can make it work because
it's like just what what do you have to
work with it and what they even let them
work with it my biggest problem with the
movies is musain and when we're watching
it I'm just like I'm just bored yeah I
just I guess it's not respects it got
the show yeah you know what but even as
a kid okay Flynn says to me was one of
the more boring cartoons I watch but
that still had things that I enjoyed as
a kid and you know what it's easier to
tolerate in the 24 minute format yeah
you bore me for two hours you know we
felt well I don't know how I don't
forget how long it actually is but that
movie felt long ya know here's the thing
I do say to myself like let's say uh
let's say Fred and Wilma in the show for
some reason had marital problems and
they broke up
like okay I'm not fan - okay what can't
be like oh like that it's kind of a
bummer that sucks like oh it had a
little bit of that heart that it's like
okay I I can see them as a couple I can
see them
existing they're just not very
interesting if they split up in the
movie who would give a shit nobody would
care if they split up I think that was
about family I was guys that was my
brown with the movie I didn't give a
shit about anything that happened like
it was literally just like a
paint-by-numbers script and it's not
like I'm not going into Flintstones
being like ooh I'm gonna be surprised
but at the same time it was just so dull
in the way they did it that it's like
okay not only am I not gonna be
surprised because it's a
paint-by-numbers script but I just don't
care yeah like I'm just not invested in
any of these characters and I will say
this with a cartoon like I I was
invested in the characters and it's a
crime really because John I'm glad John
Goodman has managed to survive after
Roseanne and everything yeah multiple
times I feel like he comes back
disappears comes back disappears but
he's managed to survive and and make a
place for himself because I think John
Goodman is one the best actors so get
out there and so I'm glad for him Rick
Moranis you know he retired but I feel
like everybody involved it was a crime
against their acting skills like the
movie just did them no favors gave them
nothing to work with you know and I
could see John Goodman trying that's the
tragedy it's like he's trying but you
could almost see the look on his eyes
like I can't do anything with this yeah
you know try I just what I have to work
with you haven't ever do the use
laughing here I'm just hoping the
theaters gonna do the same thing
yeah but scribble scrapple crap that'll
be the third film that they may know
they'll be the catchphrase um but uh
yeah I think a lot of it if there were
any laughs in the movie two scenes I got
a laugh out of me and at you this is an
example of pushing it to the next step
there's a scene where a bird is ill
clomping on the little tickets will
stone tickets when people are going in
and he turns to the camera we all know
what's coming so Lloyd
or something you Tinsley kerasys job
sucks it's like that's funny that's
taking the joke we all know I'm pushing
it to the next level no I would have
just had him say to kill me yeah we were
right we do that but they're like kids
whatever it sounds like every moment I
exist executive uh I know that are just
why are you doing this and then the
other scene I think I get this is
actually kinda to the acting is when
they're about to hang up Barney and Fred
but Barney as a job is like a snow cone
guy and when they're about to hang if
they're still paying for the snow code
is like you know is I gotta get your
cube root of twenty please don't kill me
but I gotta get fire no I don't have
change for that please me it's like that
was a little funny he just kept it going
there I don't even remember that it
shows you how much I like that that was
a little funny but like yeah I can't
remember anything else
getting a laugh or anything like that uh
and I guess like if you got little kids
and they're like yeah let's tell movie
like it's fine it's harmless I can't
think of anything that was just like oh
wow that's awful you know like that's
really gonna mess him up I mean it's
just a little child I honestly enjoyed
the Jetsons cartoon movie they came out
with in like 89 I wonder if that still
holds up cuz people have been asking me
to review that I'm just like I'm sure
you okay I'm sure it's I'm sure it's not
great but it like it's a cartoon
aphorism it had bright colors and
diverted my attention for two hours it's
like really all it needed to accomplish
like just around the fish don't even do
that just have the skeletons of those
little gizmos all around and it's like
just afterwards I'm like oh my god this
was like mass genocide in the Jessup
movie pull it out like a weird Star Trek
episode I don't yeah we're destroying
the environment this planet is but as I
said it's like it all I needed to do was
just distract me for - it it did a
better job of that than the Flintstones
there's something - like the Jetsons way
the Jetson - dev the movie did have a
much better moral I remember it was more
Bryan colourful and you could just tell
this is for like little little kids
house and okay I saw it it's fine it's
like the Care Bears movies or whatever
it's like Louis's the little little kids
we get it we can make
and stuff it's just from the Flintstones
problem was it aimed higher yeah kind of
sometimes when you aim higher you fall
longer harder farther here reach too
high on that state I did see that
witness I was demonstrating on what
happens when you aim too high
particularly with metaphor um yeah I
think it's because it was a PG movie
it's it I'll get back when I kind of
meant something they were obviously
trying to get like a grown-up
demographic as well they're trying to
make it a little bit more adult in the
advertising and the production
everything but they they missed what was
going to make this adult instead made
not even that interesting a kids movie
um so yeah just kind of a dull boring
flick if you like it mine
he hates AMA tones he hates the movie he
hates you for liking it he hates you
send all hate mail to Doug Walker I
remember he hated it a little bit too
early at you you hate it - love it
you know what just copy me crucify us
where we were trapping me on the system
crucify us on the bedroom where's -
it'll pterodactyls and like I don't know
what they use for nails back then just
more rocks smaller rock pebbles crucify
us on pebbles with pterodactyl hammers
why don't they just hit us with a rock
as long as there's a lab track after it
I think it'd be okay son ha ha ha ha I
would laugh at that my son Doug Walker
kidding stoned to death up when stuff I
would laugh are